er ist gewachsen auch was für ein baum
ist ziemlich großartig zum baum
ich finde der pasta gut hin ja aber er
ist trotzdem ziemlich riesig
na gut dann doch zwei bauen braucht also
ich zeig mal ganz kurz vor das ist
ungefähr komische höhle diesen hügel da
hinten in der ferne
ja genau da ist es okay da müssen wir
unbedingt mal rein wenn wir wüssten
jetzt gehen erstmal kurz kennen weil es
wird schon wieder nacht ok wird mir bei
der nacht des party machen muss mein
bett politiker holen um schneller kommen
wieder hoch von oben kannst du die
kamera auch ich habe ein geheimgang zur
stadt presse voll unten schon wieder
gott jetzt wieder hoch ja genau auf den
weg ich bin oben
do brasil ankommt das abo weg ja dann
gibt sie hier
erstmalig ich mach dir auf zugrunde was
kunst ist jetzt einfach kürzen
wassereimer dann richtig sagt nicht rein
springen kann kann wieder wegnehmen wird
stelle ich hier so runter zu kleiden
recht weist immer weiter von unten das
wasser hat ganz ganz langsam auf dieser
baum der irritiert mich die sieht so aus
es sei seltsam erwarte ich lieg fasten
bett ihr müsst euch wieder im bett
geschickt
eine etage unter sprechen wie kannst du
eine neue treppe schon bis jetzt so
das hat eine treppe definitiv eine
treppe ja auch so jetzt werde ich mich
erstmal in mein haus setzen und ich weiß
ich dass es so dass holz hat anstatt
sich auch so derbe komisch aus einfach
nicht so normal nicht so komisches so
vergnügt aus ich weiß nicht wie ich das
mal an ich hab die mega d was ist meine
ganzen tag mache leiter zäune ja ich
weiß dass ich mal was euch das paar aus
welchem holz nicht aus welchem haus
ich brauche so normales schnee billion
wo normale schnee bäume drinstehen davon
durch das holz
ich glaube ich begebe mich erst mal
wieder ein bisschen auf erkundungstour
mach das medienhaus bauer
das haus soll natürlich von elf von
schellen einigermaßen normal aussehen
für später von sagen genial awo der
crafter dass die schöne rassismus von
crafter sein
das kann nur von konny reimann sein
kreditrahmen wir alle denken dass sich
konny reimann heinzl nur weil du das
gesagt hast ich heiße nicht konny
reimann ich einfach luca beweist eine
identität ist du willst du noch nicht
preisgeben
nein jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft dass das
denken wirklich viele und das wäre voll
lieb wenn ihr auf fälle könnte das jetzt
überall irgendwie drunter zu schreiben
weil ist nicht stimmt konny reimann ist
so ein kleiner ort wird erhalt der
kaufkraft in niedlich abgekürzt knie und
bei conti denkt immer an den auswanderer
konny reimann viele von euch kennen den
elf durchaus sat 1 oder lief mal konny
reimann
dieser typ der immer für müller werbung
oder was auch immer ich kenne nicht dass
das erz und schnurrbart und so der ist
schnurrbart man muss zu kennen
nein kein handel an peter pan so ich
brauche jetzt diese komischen bäume
robben weg
wie hoch und hier hoch und hier und hier
hoch was ist das hier die skk komische
sträucher ich positiv es komisch medium
unterwaldt sieht zwar schön aus aber ich
brauche etwas anderes dass auch dieses
ein komisches holzstück ich mache jetzt
mein haus
das ist auch was zum brennen haben ja
dass das ist auch der gute idee wo man
die tat fünf benutzen kann man kann die
einfach verbreiten was passiert ach so
dass gekommen ich dachte in minecraft
abgestützte so was so seltsam grad ich
war irritiert als grad etwas passiert
sind die stars so di stéfano hardy jetzt
aber gut glaube ich die pannen zu bieten
was jetzt genau so viel wie die ist
konnte dann kommentiert erstmals konnte
ti richtig
ja das holz ich hab so ein komisches
pionke von mit solchen komischen bäumen
palmen bäumen oder also ein vater
vanessa wandel keine ahnung warum die
rechen ist da wo du dich verlaufen dass
neben dem sumpf ist dass er selber so
komische lila blüten kann ich aber auch
nicht abbauen doch violette blume heißt
dass diese komische sports
das heißt akazien stammt ok so schön
dass das nicht schön ist das ja das was
du brauchst ein raumschiff etwas trennen
die jetzt nicht so ein riesiges bio das
ist bei mir einfach mal stehen die
letzte tannenholz ist so hässlich finde
erst mal richtig viele sticks das geil
aus da muss ich schon sagen
allgemein die map ist sehr sehr geil
finde ich auch leitern kann's mir bitte
bescheid sagen wenn es kurz vor nacht
ist dann komme ich nämlich wieder zurück
ja und wir leben doch genau also maximal
18 minuten auf genau bestimmt meine
festklammerte leider keinen speicher wir
und dann brechen wir erste er sein ist
sozusagen das ende der erste
aufnahmestation zweiten werden schon mal
eine vollkommen richtig
als charles auguste 48 leiter
ich will das aber ich wollte es mal
nicht läuft es mit bergmann zurück
sport und schwimmen oder oder so
draußen rum und dann ich hatte auch mal
bock dass wir uns wissen das
jetzt schwarzes hinter schwarz ist was
es fließt so schwarzes wasser oder so
mit einer luft ich weiß nicht vielleicht
ist das harz oder so hartz4 davon mal
ein screenshot zu so etwas passiert
damit nicht ein laufen nur die
wasserrechte textuellen schwarz schwarz
keine ahnung ich weiß immer wenn man
einmal davon
ja es ist so weit weg 600 blöcke von
unserem normalen haus weg das heißt ich
habe einen screenshot macht das dann
irgendwie auf die folge die es gerade
ist es die angucken
übrigens frank man auch leute womit
hatte das intro für die show gemacht für
vize biest ganz einfach mit after
effects und zwar effekt denkt man immer
so war es total schwer aber eigentlich
ist das relativ einfach vor allem wenn
man in trossingen die bearbeiten will
geht das sehr sehr einfach neue bild
datei einfügen würde die ganzen film
anfang habe ich alle auf einen frame
gemacht untereinander abspielen der
beschreibung gebracht jetzt so wird
fragen zu gucken und ja auch du bist
gemeint er gar nicht fragen wollte
leider noch gebaut das möchte ich machen
nehm jetzt einmal das holz von diesem
normalen bäumen immer noch am schönsten
als sinnvoll für pilze
und macht sich gerade
ich hab kein bisschen mein haus ich habe
so ein bisschen queenston brenne ich
gerade uns nur die stars und die stars
solche sachen halt das was die abos zu
machen ich würde gern diesen diesen
kleinen ich weiß sehr oder was meint ihr
wird ein bisschen ausbauen damit ich
immer darum einfach runter zum
sprungbrett in den serien ja wäre ich
auch für dann kann ein sprungbrett auf
mein riesiges haus noch immer das meist
bei mir wird echt so farm sein so weil
ich hab voll bock seine fans betreiben
so mit tieren und allem drum und dran
qualität wirkliche fahren fahren fahren
kommen sich auf 43 von dem das wird
nicht reichen
kannst du mir sagen wenn es kurz vor
nacht ist verlangt ist das erstmal
wichtig dass du vergisst man bitte daher
um und ich sage die messestände die
treppen hoch so gerne was hier steht
eine mühle stand meine ganzen schönen
tannhäuser sinnvoll genutzt
immer in kürze also kisten leitern und
zu verbrennen halt doch so naja ich bin
gerade bäume abfahren das ist echt sehr
sehr interessant und auch die zuschauer
fühlen sich gerade glaube ich sehr
integriert in meine vorhaben hier jetzt
brauche ich das
apropos integration ihr könnt ja auch
mal schreiben also themen und sodann
dann setze ich ob er auf seiner seite da
nicht quatsch aber themen oder sowas
werde man in berlin erfolgen zunächst
oder tipps tipps sind eigentlich viel
wichtiger was kann man mit welchen
ärzten machen
wir finden hier soviel ärzte das presto
und schreibe ich heute alles immer
allein kommentar was soll mit einem
bestimmten ärzte machen kann
damit man ein bisschen übersichtlicher
bleibt kommentar und das alles verträgt
und vermüllt und alles war ja vermeiden
dank weiß er von dir zu hause richtig ja
wo ich wohne hier im hintergrund
im hintergrund wurde du meintest im
untergrund glaube ich oder
dem anwalt bleiben